So can a CART model actually
predict Supreme Court case
outcomes better than
a group of experts?
Martin and his colleagues used
628 previous Supreme Court
cases between 1994 and
2001 to build their model.
They made predictions
for the 68 cases
that would be decided
in October, 2002,
before the term started.
Their model had two
stages of CART trees.
The first stage involved
making predictions
using two CART trees.
One to predict a unanimous
liberal decision and one
to predict a unanimous
conservative decision.
If the trees gave conflicting
responses or both predicted no,
then they moved on
to the next stage.
It turns out that about
50% of Supreme Court cases
result in a unanimous decision.
So this was a nice first step
to detect the easier cases.
The second stage
consisted of predicting
the decision of each
individual justice.
And then using the majority
decision of all nine justices
as a final prediction
for the case.
In this lecture, we
constructed the CART tree
for Justice Stevens.
Here's a different tree, this
one for Justice O'Connor.
The first split
is whether or not
the lower court
decision is liberal.
If yes, then we predict that
she will reverse the case.
This makes sense because
Justice O'Connor is generally
viewed as a conservative judge.
On the other hand, if the lower
court decision is conservative,
we check for the
circuit court of origin.
If it's the second, third,
DC, or federal court,
we predict that she
will affirm the case.
If it's not one of these courts,
we move on to the next split.
The remaining two splits
are for the respondent
and the primary issue.
Here's another tree, this
one for Justice Souter.
This shows an unusual
property of the CART trees
that Martin and his
colleagues developed.
They use predictions
for some trees
as independent variables
for other trees.
In this tree, the first
split is whether or not
Justice Ginsburg predicted
decision is liberal.
So we have to run Justice
Ginsburg's CART tree first.
See what the prediction is.
And then use that as input
for Justice Souter's tree.
If Justice Ginsburg
predicted decision is liberal
and the lower court
decision is liberal,
then we predict that Justice
Souter will affirm the case.
But if the lower court
decision is conservative,
then we predict that Justice
Souter will reverse the case.
On the other side of the
tree, if Justice Ginsburg
predicted decision
is conservative,
but the lower court
decision is liberal,
then we predict that Justice
Souter will reverse the case.
But if the lower court
decision is conservative,
then we predict that Justice
Souter will affirm the case.
In summary, if we predict
that Justice Ginsburg will
make a liberal decision,
then Justice Souter
will probably make a
liberal decision too.
But if we predict that
Justice Ginsburg will
make a conservative
decision, then we
predict that Justice
Souter will probably
make a conservative
decision too.
Martin and his colleagues also
recruited 83 legal experts,
71 academics, and 12 attorneys.
38 had previously clerked
for a Supreme Court Justice,
33 were chaired
professors, and five
were current or former
law school deans.
So this was really a
dream team of experts.
Additionally, the
experts were only
asked to predict within
their area of expertise.
So not all experts
predicted all cases.
But there was more than one
expert making predictions
for each case.
When making their
predictions, the experts
were allowed to consider
any source of information.
But they were not
allowed to communicate
with each other regarding
the predictions.
For the 68 cases
in October, 2002,
the predictions were made,
and at the end of the month
the results were computed.
For predicting the
overall decision that
was made by the Supreme
Court, the models
had an accuracy of 75%,
while the experts only
had an accuracy of 59%.
So the models had a significant
edge over the experts
in predicting the
overall case outcomes.
However, when the
predictions were
run for individual justices,
the model and the experts
performed very similarly.
For some justices, the
model performed better.
And for some justices, the
experts performed better.
Being able to predict
Supreme Court decisions
is very valuable to
firms, politicians,
and nongovernmental
organizations.
We saw in this lecture
that a model that
predicts overall Supreme
Court decisions is both more
accurate than experts and can
be run much faster than experts
can make their predictions.
The CART models
that we built were
based on very high level
components of the cases,
compared to the
experts who can process
much more detailed and
complex information.
This example really
shows the edge
that analytics can provide
in traditionally qualitative
applications.